[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting
you are in for a treat i'm excited about
this i've been looking forward to this
one we want to introduce you
to
our other best friend in college
who we've kept in touch with i mean
we'll get into some of that but we want
to introduce you to the one the only
greg
hearts field
greg you're here well no you're not
i made it
you made it you made it to your your
home and a phone that you're
communicating through and uh you're in
the you're in washington state yes i'm
there that's that's where right is here
we're still in burbank
now we've talked about greg
a lot throughout the years i mean most
recently if you watch our other show of
mythical morning uh you know that
the the black base that was on the set
for
basically many years basically most most
of the history of the show
was a base that greg gave us when he
left to go to argentina right after
college so we're talking like 20 years
ago
so we had the bass the bass was played
in a few early retin-link songs when i
would lay down a bass line we later
realized that i could just play the
guitar and then we would just lower an
octave in garageband yeah yeah um
but
recently greg asked for the bass back
and so that whole story is unfolding on
good mythical morning but and so by the
way if if you have something that you
think can fit in that
space that the base was that occupied
you let us know there's a twitter post
you post your your photo and your
basically your sales pitch as to why
this thing is special hopefully it's the
base i'm trying to lobby for the basis
for alabama
to donate one of his bases i just think
that would be funny if he won't then we
are just hoping for a guy named greg
preferably a guy named greg with two g's
at the end
so greg have you received the base back
it's here it's here
it needs to be restrung
you have not maintained the base
it wasn't broken when it arrived it just
needs to be refreshed
yes it needs it needs a light buffing
and something strings yeah i mean
bass strings do not last two decades
they probably last like
you know you might get i don't know six
months out of some bass strings now
listen if you don't replace these
strings and play this thing within like
the next two weeks
you're at risk of us asking you
years from now if you played it and
you'll be like you'll be embarrassed
you'll have to start lying to us that
you're playing it so
you need to get on it man i'm i'm
working on the plan i uh
i
i was i didn't have a plan until just
now so now i have a plan
i don't really know the details of the
plan but there's a plan there's plenty
how good did you get it based before you
gave us that base i was i was not so
good um you know on a on a from one to
ten i might be a two okay right
you've been holding steady at a two i
did go to a
jazz club in raleigh and went open mic
night one time and and for some reason
people thought that played bass well
but i don't think i did are you talking
about when you were in college no that
was
after college i went with uh
tom from our church okay and you did a
little you little bass thing man i
didn't know you were moonlighting i do
remember that you had an acoustic guitar
when we first met you could probably i
think you could play some grateful dead
songs but
all right so tell us what do you
remember about meeting us for the first
time so i you know i've spent the last
uh 30 minutes trying to
to recreate this memory in my mind it
doesn't nothing really pops out but i
uh
when i first met you guys
i
think
it was a pres freshman year college and
uh
and i saw
i
read up on the stage at crew and
and i was like there's that guy up there
that didn't really care you know didn't
really even want to be at the meeting we
really didn't meet in my recollection
until sophomore year so well if that was
the first time you saw me that was your
sophomore year because i did because i
may have gotten up front freshman year
for something but i wasn't emceeing
until because i lobbied
to mc my freshman year
knowing that the guy who was a senior
was graduating oh okay so i talked to
mark and was like what can i can i emcee
you know next year
so you must have because i remember i
remember it being the beginning of
sophomore year
that was definitely when we became
friends like pretty early on sophomore
year
um
but
what was your impression of us i mean i
remember my impression of you but i'll
let you go first what whatever you
remember of like when we first started
becoming friends sophomore year
it was within the context of the campus
crusade like
todd smith who was and still is a
full-time staff member
he was like leading bible studies and
like organizing the weekly meeting and a
lot of this
a lot of the organizational stuff that
happened on campus
with the with the organization
but like he he knew you
and then he knew us and then we must
have met through todd right i think so i
think so but i i
i don't i don't recall i i know that
like we real we hit it off i mean i i we
hung out all the time
yeah we were fast friends hanging out
with you guys
so
the thing that i remember is
i mean
i i don't remember the specific thing
but i have to know that our first
impression of
greg was
this dude is different
this i mean
i mean and take this in a positive way
but like i was like this dude is strange
and and and funny
and like just different than anybody
else we knew so like we were very much
drawn to like
um
you know everybody in campus crew said i
don't know it's just like everybody's
fit into a certain mold well i mean greg
you stood out you were like this like
super skinny
dude with like this real floppy clothes
like us like you were dressing like a
huge
thing so
we were at nc state which is already you
know it's a technical school right it's
a technical state school in the south
and we were also then sort of filtered
into this
uh christian group so
there was a little more like
for lack of a better word like
southern preppiness so right so you know
there's a certain i don't know if you
grew up in the south you know exactly
what i'm talking about but like a guy
who would wear a polo shirt and a you
know
a trucker hat it was a little fratish
it's a little fragile but not full-on
frat so you're not quite redneck and not
quite preppy and that was most of the
people now we kind of came in thinking
that we were going to be rock stars you
know we're dying our hair bleaching our
hair wearing these big baggy pants
alternative
embracing the alternative 90s so we were
really leaning hard into that and it
wasn't difficult to stand out because
there wasn't a lot of people in our
small circle doing that and then greg
comes along and it was immediately like
oh this guy
he feels like he's on a very similar
wavelength i mean and
we thought that you were a stoner like
in like a really
like you have this delivery like i i
remember whenever we would see
greg would be like what's going on
okay yeah so there was some recovering
stoner thing happening
so by the time we met you you were like
yeah you were
you were being introduced to the
straight and narrow uh through campus
crusade and like
we were besides
todd was trying to bring you into the
fold basically right yeah and yeah he
was he was putting in me and my you know
in the right place
yeah and when when when he introduced us
i was like
we just kind of
we we just found you very funny very
entertaining whenever we would say
what's up you remember what greg would
say good good
this is like anybody who that's what
like nobody's response to what's up is
good
and every time and you were always good
you were always good how else do you
respond to that question i mean
well you i mean you want me to break it
down logically because i mean when you
say what's up what you're asking is like
what is up like like what's going on
you're asking you're asking how are you
doing well i mean you got to cut to the
chase if you say what's up you could you
could respond with like well i i'm good
that's one of the things this up but you
were just like good
nothing much man
i'm headed to class
i'm going back to my dorm you want to
come over and play some twisted metal
really the the proper response at that
age with a familiar person to what's up
is what's up
yeah just you just say it back but no no
one but i didn't want you to say
everything
said good and that's why we knew
that you had to be
a constant part of our lives i think
that
you know
we were in this place we had gone
through our freshman year together like
we had made a lot of friends
we hadn't really
um
like really found our like our group it
was it was just the two of us on the
weekends i was still i was going back
home see my girlfriend we were still
involved in our band the wax paper dogs
so freshman year was like this
transition period but like sophomore
year
we had basically decided we were
deciding to squit the band you were
deciding and lobbying to be the emcee of
campus crusades weekly meeting i was
already
involved in the music team of the weekly
meeting so i was up front
singing uh
leading the music so i was like
we were moving in these positions where
we were like visible positions early on
and so like college for us at the
beginning of sophomore year was
okay i've broken up with my girlfriend
now it's like all in on college and
right about that same time very early on
we meet
and it was just like
it was
always
fun to have you around so it was just
like
let's it i mean in a lot of ways we
became this trio
very quickly like i i mean do you
remember any more of what you thought of
us i'm not fishing for a compliment but
like i mean i told you that i thought
you were basically
gloriously weird and it was like unlike
anybody else so i was like
let's do this
i just thought you guys were
you know
my friends i just i just wanted to you
know i had
in my life
i haven't had
you know a ton of friends up to that
point i meet you too i was like this is
my people this is who
this is who i i want to hang out with
you know so i mean
you see like you were you were in wood
dorm which was like halfway across
campus in a weird spot where we didn't
know anybody and it was a suite and you
were you spent a lot of time with jack
freshman year you had a number of
friends that were suite mates right
yeah i had yeah yeah and so
because now that i think about it
because junior year which we'll get to
in a second
we moved off campus
because we met at the beginning of
sophomore year it turns out that a lot
happened during sophomore year because
sophomore year was our last year in syme
dorm so that was
when you know syme dorm room 24 which
has since been turned into a storage
closet
because the window opens up underneath
the stairs but that was that was the
year that we got into
smoking cigars
we would crawl out through that window
in that little area i have fond memories
of that window tell us what you remember
well i i remember you know we would
smoke cigars
did we did we get into the pipes by that
point yes pipes by george
oh it was it was low
we had there was some chairs it was
chairs permanently staged out in the
in the the under the stairs area and
there was a dirt floor it was dark and
damp
yeah because it was okay so it was it
wasn't good for like our respiratory
health the only window for our dorm room
like walking out the sign they would you
can hear them walking out talking
right because the the main entrance to
sign was like these like huge
uh cement stairs
and then underneath that staircase
was like
it was just open air but it was that's
where our window was so our window never
got sunlight and we would open the
window
and we would crawl out of our window
into underneath the stairs where
everybody's walking into the first floor
and there's bushes on both sides so it
was like completely walled in it was
like a cave like you couldn't you
probably could have but you didn't go
from underneath the stairs outside no we
never did that it was like it was in
close i'm so sad that they made that
into a not a room anymore because it was
the best room it was great to be a
college student there because students
don't need sunlight no matter what time
of day it was you could sleep it was
like having
uh
room darkening blinds but it was just
this the the staircase and i remember
yeah
if you didn't get us into cigars i don't
know who did
but what would happen was you'd say hey
let's let's hang out
and we'll smoke cigars and you would
come over
backwards we started with back we were
not doing
fine well it's because we didn't have a
lot of money i do remember we would save
up and you would you were like we need
to go to this place called pipes by
george and we would go down on
hillsborough street it's still there oh
you checked the last time you went yeah
it's still there and
george you knew george because you had
been in there yep was
first name basis with george
and you remember what his catchphrase
was
uh no he well he would say pipe uh pack
in the pipe you know pack it like a baby
pack it like a mama and pack it like a
daddy or something like that but when
you asked him about like what do you
think about this one oh smooth
they were all smooth it's real smooth
everything i was like george do you have
a tobacco that's not smooth
no i specialize in smooth
so we would go in there and we would buy
cigars and we'd save up money to get
like the nicer ones like a seven dollar
cigar and i remember that was a big
fight we would go sit underneath the
stoop and you're right there was like
dirt it was a dirt floor it was dank and
dark under there
and
one day i mean like you would call and
be like
i'm coming over and then he came over
and
greg was dragging a chair and we're like
where did you get this this looks like
one of the chairs
from the student center
do you remember that yeah i remember now
yeah i wouldn't remember that but yeah
yeah brought the chair over you you
brought you borrowed it permanent hold
on he was a student he was a student i
mean he's paying tuition it's his chair
just because it's not currently in the
student center doesn't mean he can't use
it he didn't take it off campus he just
brought it to the little hole under the
stairs that was our level of subversion
it was like you know we were so by the
book and i'm talking capital b book here
and i mean greg you were very much like
i don't do you remember us being like
very pious
but then i guess to finish my point
answer the question is like
whenever he would come over and he's
stolen a chair and we're like smoking
cigars and we're like just blowing all
the smoke around the entrance to the it
just felt i just felt like we were
being well we were edgy i i think i i
wouldn't say that we were pious we were
zealous there's a very distinct
difference between those things right
pius is someone who is right obsessed
with
rule following now we were good good
guys and everything but we were zealous
it was more about belief about our
belief in our faith but but also rules i
remember
that
time being
the first time not that we didn't do
this before but
you know when you're sitting under the
stairs smoking a cigar is when you start
just talking about stuff and considering
a night out
just having a three-hour conversation
about something yeah
every every weekend that was the
beginning of that being a staple because
we weren't going out and partying nope
you know do you remember us being
zealous like was that a part of the
equation of like
these guys are different no that that
wasn't part of the equation i i did i do
think you might have been zealous
yeah but uh i never really took that
into account to be honest with you
because if you i mean if you came from a
place where
you know
you were doing things that like were off
limits for us
right so then like once you were once
you came into the fold and like
i mean
like you were todd was trying to get you
into campus crusade once you became our
friend it was just like
you were all in
at that point which came first like
being friends with us or being
christians did like we did we rope you
into like
really
going all in for jesus no you guys
didn't um
i i think like well you know
this this kind of goes to
your guys's uh deconstruction
yeah um i i had i've thought about this
a lot actually um
because when i was when i became a
christian i met you guys shortly
thereafter right
and
like it you know it i i've thought
like what what what does this say about
me like
this does their deconstruction what the
effect does that have on me but you know
i kind of
i kind of realized that like i
deconstructed
many years before um
you know i grew up in christian home and
at some point i said this this is not
for me you know this is not this is not
i don't even know what i'm doing um so
i i kind of rethought the whole thing
and ended up where i am so where where i
was at
that point in time and
you know you guys were just you guys
were just great friends i just loved
being around you and
and i you know i still wish
i could relive it all it was it was a
wonderful time of life to to hang out
and
yeah nothing beats those college years
you know
that it's those are the the best years
that i that i remember yeah because it's
like like you said ha the definition of
entertainment was just the three of us
hanging out for hours just talking just
talking and i think you know it was
there was no
yeah we were just getting a kick out of
each other it's just being on the same
wavelength and there just being that
i also think greg you brought this
dynamic into our i have to think it's
like i'm i'm projecting a little bit
because i don't i don't remember
thinking this at the time and it i don't
i don't remember us talking about greg
talking about you when you weren't
around but i have to think looking back
on it that like
as close as rhett and i were
there was something to bring like you
mix things up like you bringing a third
person into the
equation
um it kind of opened things up there's
lots of things where it's like
you know the if the two of us are
talking
and it's even true now a lot of times
like if we hang out with people there's
this dynamic that's like
we've heard so much about each other we
we've lived so much of our lives
together and know so much it's like you
bring somebody into it who's newer to
the equation
um
it it opens up the conversation it makes
it to where you can talk you can cover
new ground you can have a different
perspective
and i think you were so
your sense of humor and
just you were so game for conversation
and it was a you came from a different
place
well wilmington
but then like it was just like okay this
is
this is a new
this guy has a different vibe he's he's
cool he's weird he's got interesting
perspective he's funny
um
it i think it had to have breathed
it had been a breath of fresh air into
our friendship to open it up in that way
i kind of see like you know you guys you
guys are
been best friends for for a long time um
and you know i think it speaks volumes
to to your friendship
that you would allow a third best friend
into that
dynamic and it didn't affect you guys at
all i mean we can i could hang out with
red or i could hang out with link or we
could all hang out together you all
could hang out with each other and it
was like there was no question
that the friendship was true that there
was never any you know
worrying that you know rhett had a new
best friend or link had a new best
friend that it was just
it was it was truly you know this
perfect three three-way friendship it
was a perfect three-way yeah that's how
we definitely thought about it but yeah
i i was thinking about that too well
i think that we were always
without stating it
we're always looking for somebody
to be like the third person in our
friendship
um but that takes
a special person
right because we didn't know we were
looking for it but i think i i do think
when we found it in greg it was just
very natural
it ha it has happened a few times in our
lives
but it's the reason it's a challenge is
because
you know
we both have to like the person which
isn't always the case right and it's not
that you like people that i don't like
or i like people that you don't like is
that we're we are both pretty particular
in terms of like where we're going to
invest our time and who's going to be
our who's going to be our friend and
this could have always been the case
we're both very tough and as we said we
like
spending time with people and then like
retreating and analyzing the person
and the experience the two of us later
and i think if we ever talked about you
greg it was like
all the stuff that i've already said and
it was all positive and like there was
this vibe that yeah i'm actually very
surprised that there was something about
the nature of our dynamic
that you brought something that i wasn't
threatened by you know because i have to
think that that that very well could
have been
part of the equation
um but it but it never was because we
did hang out
i want to talk about the the dynamic
with how we did hang out how we spent
our time and it was you hung out with
greg a lot more than i did during well
we'll talk about why that was but
one of the things that happened early on
that sophomore year i'll see if you
remember this and i don't remember
exactly how it came up
but we got you to cut your hair
like if you remember
your
mop top your freshman year haircut and
then you went basically just like buzz
and you and you basically had the buzz
cut for
a very long time after that do you
remember what did i cut his hair did you
did that i cut your hair i'm sure we all
cut each other's hair we had we had the
clippers yeah
you were cutting my hair in college for
sure you don't remember
us talking you into cutting your hair no
i thought i thought i always had that
haircut
no dude when we met you freshman year
man you had a lot of hair on top it had
like a head look like a wig well we
caught we called it the mushroom you had
a mushroom dude we gave you a makeover
and then you guys i mean whenever you
guys would hang out without me
it would you'd be playing twisted metal
but let's establish why i mean
you
studied
all the time i studied a lot my freshman
year
i studied a whole lot my freshman year
i got all a's and i was like okay
been there done that
this wasn't
i
this doesn't need to be what college is
about so starting sophomore year i was
like i'm going to study enough to like
get out of here with a respectable gpa
but but you also had another guy who you
who wasn't me that gave you opportunity
to do stuff well and then granted i was
not giving you anything greg is famous
for the line when i was over there at
his place and we were getting ready to
play another round see if he remembers
of twisted metal because that was our
game you remember that twisted metal was
a game now do you remember what you told
me when i was like i gotta go study man
you know what you know you don't learn
anything
i live by that you know what you know
you don't learn anything and then there
was like this corollary of like
everything
i learned on
everything i know i learned in
kindergarten was that also you no i
don't i don't think so okay i just have
to think kindergarten the
catchphrase i mean you know what you
know you don't learn anything it's
interesting in the dynamic that you're
talking about with not feeling
threatened because greg and i did end up
spending a lot of time together playing
video games eating gumby's pizza like
again like you and like you're not you
don't really you've never really been in
a video games you're not really into
food yeah so the idea of like we're
gonna go and get off extra large pizza
and sit on a bench and eat the whole
thing right right that's just not link
neal stuff so it was like yeah but i had
somebody who was like yeah i do like to
eat pizza in the middle of the night and
i do like to not study and play video
games and so
me and greg had something so for you
from your perspective
greg
filled
a felt need that you had that i couldn't
fulfill as your best friend i wonder if
we look at it the other way like for me
i
i don't
what did we what did we do together greg
without rhett
i don't know i i know that the the years
the you know after college like we i
hung out with you more a lot more than i
got with red
it's like almost two different stages
there yeah yeah we had another we had a
post-college
stage where um
you know we were both
you know newlyweds starting our
marriages christy and jim were good
friends but we go to the same church we
went to the same church
yeah so that's why like
we we had like
now first stage of post-college
adulthood
i would go over to your house and like
you still have that homer simpson grill
like it was a yellow grill it looked
like from the simpsons i had one of
greg's bristles
you still have it still have it yeah but
to go back to
sophomore year yeah so you would go over
there you would play twisted metal and
then let's get into the the prime time
of it all because
you took over garrett was a senior
a freshman year ish he was he was the mc
he was leaving
you he pulled you under his wing and you
were just waiting for
him and todd to ask you
to step up and be the emcee you were
lobbying for that
um
and i was in support of that but like
you were having these it was like there
was these like recruiting conversations
it was it was interesting but then you
got the job
there was no pay
and then because i was already up front
we were kind of we were both in that the
most visible roles as students to like
shape what the weekly meeting looked
like
and
of course
you know we would talk about
um
we would talk about like you'd be
working up stuff that you were gonna do
in your monologue i'd like to walk
through what a primetime episode would
look like but of course greg
you were wrapped up in all this because
we were a trio like if if we were both
shaping the meeting and having ideas
i think pretty quickly
you
got involved on stage two basically as
uh the andy richter to rhett's conan
or ed mcmahon to his johnny carson well
i just remember thinking great
sidekick i just remember thinking greg
was hilarious that everybody thought
that he was funny
and he had really interesting ways of
saying things
yeah and so
i was just like why don't you come up
and just give a deep thought so it was
obviously a throwback to the jack handy
thing from snl days but it was just like
greg do you have a deep thought for us
and then
i honestly don't remember how those were
concocted
i don't know i remember i remember how
they were concocted okay we would sit
back before the meeting and you guys
would we would all come up with this
deep thought and you guys would
perfectly plan out what i was going to
say and i could i could never say it
never say it quite as written but there
was which was part of the
part of the thing that made it great and
then a lot of times i would um
you and i would be working on it because
rhett you'd be working on the other
stuff you'd be working on your monologue
right so then while you're getting
prepared last minute for that greg you
and i would be over on the side
and i would be drilling you in this in
your deep thought do you i mean you do
remember the the preamble to it right
that was the same every time yeah yeah i
i didn't mess that up i don't think
let's hear it after much deep thought
and great meditation i've come to the
realization
that
that
and then you would say it i don't
i don't know i don't remember one yeah i
don't remember any of that yeah after
much deep thought great meditation i've
come to the realization that if you're
gonna walk backwards
you're only seeing where you've been and
but
that's not a bad thing
if you're about to walk off a cliff i
don't know i made that up but it would
they would be
that nonsense
and they were very unrelated they
weren't themed to anything that i was
talking about because what i was doing
every single week is i
i mean this was again this is one of my
favorite times in the in in my life
because
i had this audience and i basically was
like i'm writing a stand-up routine
an original stand-up routine every
single week i was much more excited
about that than i was studying yeah and
it was just like okay well this week i'm
going to tell this story or this week
i'm going to do this and i remember one
week i was like i had gotten so much
confidence was way overconfident
i was like this week i'm not letting
myself think about any of it until i'm
up there and i'm doing it all off the
cuff i don't think that one went that
well
but it was just such a
i mean it was really the the the the
the of course the there was the video
aspect so that probably was about one
out of ten let's paint a picture for how
this went so um we did that like two
times this semester the weekly meeting
every thursday night there'd be it would
start you know i think when you started
it was like maybe it might have been a
few hundred people
and then that was sophomore year junior
year senior year by senior year there
was like it was the largest
uh
campus
group there was like over a thousand
students coming to this thing they had
to start
like moving the venue and it was it was
just it was a it wasn't just because of
any one thing
i mean
the fact that yeah like there was a lot
of comedy involved it was very fun it
was a fun environment to be in but there
were so that was a factor there were
other factors too but i think it
definitely was a positive contribution
to like
the numbers growing every week it became
kind of this spectacle if you're gonna
show up to this thing
and
in my mind
i was i was very much a part of it
obviously in your mind you were the
center of it as the host and greg as a
sidekick but like in our in our how in
our whenever we'd get together sophomore
year and then junior year when we moved
into an apartment the three of us
together it was like the epicenter of
planning like working with todd on
planning an epis an episode i mean
a meeting yeah so the meeting would
start with like singing
and i would lead the singing so i would
be up there and like saying stuff in
between songs and kind of scratching
that itch of like
having an audience
and but it was very experienced it was
very very spiritual i had to stay in my
lane
but then
the next thing that would happen is you
would come out as the mc and like do a
welcome
but a lot of times
we saw that as an opportunity to create
a video it wasn't our and they had done
this in years past create a video where
um
it would be this
comedy lead up to you it would always be
you're doing something some sort of
adventure or something
and then the way the video would always
end is you walking up the stairs to the
front of the venue and then you would
come in and you'd be there so it would
seem like a continuation of the video
live and in reality i think we probably
only did that at the beginning of each
semester because we just didn't have
because literally we had to make the
videos and then i was going home
to my dad's office in bowie's creek and
editing them on two vcrs like this was
still before
a non-linear editing system and so we
just we would
i mean if we were in college right now
we've been doing videos every single
week but it's just there was we didn't
have the capacity to do it so at first
you would just come out maybe without a
video but then when we started making
videos
you and greg would come out as a duo
yeah as a comedy duo the two of you will
come out and so the the video was a set
piece to introduce the two of you
whenever we could make those and i was
the
director
dp
i was the cameraman right and i would
kind of
i mean
you and i were very involved in coming
up with what these videos would be
and um
and then
it would be kind of some sort of
storyline
sometimes like greg will be lost or you
would be like fighting i don't know i
had to like find greg a couple of times
but and then i think one of them you
actually carry carried you in he carried
greg in
like he was like
passed out or dead or something i never
i never thought of this but why did i
never find red
why because you were the sidekick you
were the psycho i had to find you in
order to you know feel complete you
would come down the aisle together and
then would you would stand on the side
rhett would do his monologue i would be
sitting in the audience laughing the
loudest i was basically doing what
stevie does in good mythical morning
you're like the crowd uh
you know like though the person who says
the icebreaker i'd break it's okay to
laugh it's okay to laugh applause coach
yeah
i would laugh not applaud but
so greg you would be standing up there
the whole time that rhett was given his
monologue and occasionally
rhett would turn to you and like have an
exchange
if he wanted to but otherwise you were
just kind of standing there
awkwardly
waiting to give your deep thought which
was hilarious not and i'm the deep not
the deep thought the fact that you were
just standing up there
was just kind of funny to me
like
and then
well you would say something like greg
and you would know it would have a
pattern video or not monologue uh and
then you would turn to greg and say
hey greg
or you might say what's up greg can i be
like good i'd say like greg you've been
thinking about anything like we always
set it up everyone wouldn't expect
this really anticlimactic deep thought
that
i was waiting for you to totally screw
up which was
an added layer of but you i mean you
were good at it like something about
always delivery i mean people loved it
people loved it every time and then
after that we'd probably sing some more
songs have there might be like
promotions for different events and then
there'd be a speaker and then there'd be
more songs and that would be it so it's
like really the beginning was about
the comedy well that's the interesting
thing is that
you know at the beginning of every
meeting in addition to the funny
monologue i would have to say
you know campus crusade for christ is
the internominational christian
organization founded in 1951 by and and
i would do the spiel and i would be like
our we we operate on a three i would
make it different every time but say
like three-pronged philosophy of win
build sin win students to christ build
them up in their faith and send them out
to continue the wind build sin process
like i said stuff like that all the time
and you became like a spokesman and i
would and then there was this weird
dynamic of your b and this really became
a thing during christmas conference but
being trying to be as funny as possible
and then being spiritual because
a pastor would come up and speak and do
like a serious talk
right it's usually started humorously
and then ended in a serious place and
then i got to get up there after that
and at this point this is all no all the
fun and games are over and i got to say
something that sounds like the like the
student response to this thing thank you
so much that talked about an impact on
you but greg the thing i want to talk to
you about is do you know that
so obviously after we graduated and we
were engineers for a while then lincoln
i went on staff a crusade to kind of do
our comedy
ministry thing
and during the the support raising
process you would have to kind of talk
about you get you know you got to give
your spiel and kind of explain what
you're doing
and link
link i was going to bring this up
because i was there for one of these
meetings oh you were so
yes i was there when link was was uh
presenting the fact that
rhett and link were coho were hosting
the the weekly meeting and i and i
looked at link i was like hmm
yeah and link's simplified story that he
would give to supporters he he wrote he
oh he he overwrote you with himself
and you were in the room for it
yeah i i heard the spill i was there for
one of the presentations i think you
gave me some money
thank you
well listen and you know i was
to me i was justified in doing it
because it was just too complicated to
try to explain completely understand why
you did it you weren't you were you were
you upset no
yeah you were talking to like a 65 year
old person in kinston north carolina
yeah who well apparently i was talking
to greg at one time
no no you were we
for some reason you and i went up to
asheville for something and i
and you were you were scrounging for
supporters and i was like well i
i know some people in nashville so we we
these were my contacts
yes that's what you took into asheville
and then he told the story about him
yeah
it probably didn't occur to me as i was
saying it i don't think they supported
you they could see through your life
yeah
yeah the perfect opportunity to be like
you know and greg was up there
like you had the perfect that was a you
could have used greg's connection to
these people you probably won't come out
of there i was using greg that's very
clear at this point but uh not in the
right way greg i'm sorry for uh for
erasing you in my revisionist history
before that you know i think there there
were moments when okay you moved from by
junior year they asked you rhett to host
to be the emcee for the regional
christmas conference
and by this point
when you did that
i was involved
less at first but then more and more
over time and that's where we became a
comedy duo on stage
but the way that that happened was first
of all
greg i'm i'm interested in your
perspective on this because
at that point
like the
the the greg sidekick thing didn't i
don't remember how but it didn't
transfer over to the regional christmas
conference well i i i didn't replace you
i remember this immediately the first
time okay so the first year i did it
um the only time that you were on stage
was during the music right during the
the comedy music not the worship music
the song the original songs that we
would write together and the first song
was the unibrow song which was the song
that we wrote when we wrote the song for
your rehearsal dinner
uh
which was we've seen greg naked soon you
will too whatever that one hope you
enjoy it more than we do so when we got
up there it was actually
you
and tim and greg nope greg wasn't there
it's just you and tim
no and i think the reason i was getting
married i was getting married right
there you were moving on that's why you
went out of the picture you weren't you
didn't go to christmas conference
you were engaged you were moving on we
were writing we had written and
performed
um
at least one song
for
seniors at the
nc state weekly meeting so we had
started writing some songs
that first song that we ever performed
at a prime time nc state meeting for
seniors i don't want to go into the
details of it it was yes but um
it was me
but by senior year
we had tim move in with us in our
apartment so
me you and tim were each playing a
three-headed person who was singing back
up to you yeah singing so that was the
first song we ever played but then the
second song that i remember
was
was a unibrow song which tim still came
up there for that at christmas and then
after that there was no more
tim
playing
singing songs with us and i moved more
into a sidekick and then a co-host
once i was no longer a student and me
and you were doing our comedy thing
together and also talking about going on
staff
is when like
right at the beginning of the whole
conference we would both get up there
together so it was like the third year
yeah or something like that
so in retrospect from that point ren and
i were a comedy duo we were doing this
full-time and when you worked backwards
like we had done it
in christmas conference so many years
that like when you go back you know
four or five years then yeah i kind of
become you in the story just so i can
get that money
now just to simplify greg did you ever
find yourself thinking man i mean
he's not asking me to do the deep
thoughts at christmas conference because
you never told me that no i never
thought that never okay good i don't
feel bad i ran out of adults
you ran you ran out of deep thoughts you
stopped thinking deeply after college
you haven't been writing them down every
week for
for 22 years well
rewinding a little bit
to that junior year because again
the first time the two so that was the
year we moved off campus right and this
is the first time
that the two of us ever lived with
anyone else so of course we had lived
together freshman and sophomore year in
our dorm but when we decided to move off
campus to gorman crossings apartment
3000 c
i'm sure it was a no-brainer that it was
going to be the three of us yeah yeah
that only made sense right it was so
exciting like i remember that moment too
of just like hey we're getting we're
getting an apartment yeah like we had
stairs in it we each don't didn't no
when we did the tour it had stairs i
remember the tour had stairs in it it
was a two-story one and then we ended up
getting the one the one story one is
what we ended up renting but i was like
this is so crazy there's carpet
on stairs like i don't know why that was
fascinating to me oh yeah we didn't get
that one we thought that gorman
crossings was so nice it was a three
bedroom apartment we each had our own
bedroom it had it it had a sliding glass
doors off the living room that went
right into like this stoop and i was
like this is our new stoop we now have
sunlight we get to sit out here and have
our three-hour conversations and smoke
pipes by george
um so yeah like
play in-house with your best friends it
was like so much fun like we moved mr
fly our couch into there we
we decorated the room with
the lionel vinyl and the michael jackson
thriller vinyl we found a couch out by
the dumpster that looked
similar to mr play
it was like a golden and green do you
remember that yep and we and we brought
in we every all the furniture was
probably from thrift stores oh yeah
pretty janky and i remember you had a
thing for the label maker yeah yeah i i
labeled things
you would label things for comedic
effect
yep yep still do like our vcr
said vcr on it
which reminds me of
the the big godmaking
yeah initiative that i think was i was i
was in a relationship
i was dating christy do you remember i
was on the fringe of this greg do you
remember our the godmaking idea that we
had yeah i i think we had that idea
while we were going out the mission
valley 1.50 theater
this is where this is where the the plan
really got hashed out yeah but it it it
it culminated with the uh the plan of
the apes
movie marathon yeah so for those for the
initial uninitiated for those of you who
weren't there that night god macking it
was me and greg's idea to
uh and this goes very much against what
we're being told by campus crusade
you find a girl who's not a christian or
maybe she's not a serious christian
and you
you date her
with the intention that she would become
a christian
and really it was it was
i think it was because we were a little
bit good they were a little bit
frustrated with the pool of women that
we had at our you know disposal and
campus crusade
and we just wanted to uh we wanted to
expand the circle and the only way we
could justify it is
evangelistic it was it was an act of
evangelism how do you remember the
planet of the apes idea i don't know you
know like every good idea how who came
up with it i don't know but i know that
we had multiple tvs and we had a vcr
and we we figured out a way to hook
multiple tvs to one vcr you yeah you
that's a classic greg there was planet
of the apes in every single room it was
a part you created a closed circuit
television system
so
in anticipation for
so many
women who you didn't know we wanted it
to be us and all women that was the plan
so
you went around campus
and started inviting and we would go out
there
strange women we would just go out to
group strange girls talking and be like
uh how you guys doing um
yeah we're showing
planet of the eighth century
some girls came they did they showed up
i mean not many we had more tvs than we
needed not more tvs than women but you i
mean to your credit there was there was
a good number of women there i would say
there were at least eight women there
and i walked in and i didn't know any of
them
and and planet of the apes was showing
on at least two televisions i don't know
if there was a third one yeah and greg
we didn't provide any like
i if i recall was there food there
definitely was there was no alcohol
i don't know if we even had drinks and
food man like we didn't know how to
throw a party
we were just like they're just going to
be interesting why would you need drinks
and food there's plenty of the apes
oh man i would love to hear one no
relationships came out of that i would
love to hear one of those girls describe
that
like they're out there somewhere and
they're just like i think it would kind
of invite me to this thing yeah some
strangers invited me to their apartment
to watch planet of the apes they they
really build it up as a big deal
um i'm sure they don't even remember it
because it was not memorable they did
not mention jesus no because you can't
do that because you did one you got to
use planet of the apes as a segue into
the gospel right bait and switch they
call that
so you baited him with with planet of
the eighth and yeah so i think they
would say well we showed up and they
were watching planet of the apes on um
on vcr
and uh the couches were kind of ratty
there was no food um they seemed very
excited that we were there and then we
left i think that's what they would say
yeah
so maybe it's not all you hoped it would
be
yeah but hey you know what it was it
took a lot of initiative and you guys
really again i was in a relationship you
guys are trying to play
you still are
i got married first okay greg you got
married second i got married in may you
got married in december and then r you
got married the next june right all
within the one calendar year but
i mean and all still married to the same
lovely women
so greg you you jotted down some stuff
one other thing here
about relative relevant to what we're
talking about there was this girl named
lindsey
like i was i was talking to lindsay
that's this is this is the one
i will ever pick with rhett and i've
never done it so here i go oh i'm oh
yeah i'm excited about this oh yeah i
thought you would be there was this girl
named lindsey yep well i remember
lindsay was interested in me and i was
interested in lindsay until rhett
rhett got involved
what happened well i know the next thing
next thing lindsay likes rhett
but she didn't though you were talking
to her right did you go out on a date
the date was
was you know it was it was about to
happen it was it was imminent it was
imminent yes yes imminent but like in
your mind it was imminent
yes definitely and did hold on did you
tell me did i know this did i know that
you liked her
i remember it
i remember greg liked her i remember
rhett sort of like hinting like would it
be okay if if i talk to lindsey
i mean you know what do you say to your
friend when they ask if they can you you
were my god macking partner i mean i
just thought it was just it
no i honestly do not i do not remember
because when i think about lindsay what
i remember is
liking her
and then
she immediately went on summer project
and when she came back she was dating
one of the guys that she met on summer
project and when you meet somebody else
on her project even though it's from
another school you've got on like summer
project glasses you know and you
you think you're in love i don't call
him goggles goggles she probably ended
up marrying him who knows but
i'm sorry greg i didn't know that you
were you were moving in sorry for what
give a full apology i'm sorry for
moving in on you and a girl that you
were interested in oh well i i'm i'm
over it i'm over it
i don't think i really understood that
there was a there was something there i
didn't know that that was happening
i thought you were just like yeah she's
hot and i was like yeah she is hot maybe
i could talk to her maybe maybe i
shouldn't have said anything then well i
mean you know it all worked out for the
best obviously yeah nobody ended up with
she won the summer project she ended up
with somebody yeah if she wanted to you
got a lot we wish you the best go on
summer project but i didn't it does
remind i mean if you said you didn't get
upset at that like there were some
signature moments where greg would get
upset like you had this signature way of
getting mad
that was
hilarious
and it i mean literally we would when
you would get really angry we would
laugh and it would do nothing but make
you more angry just makes it matter like
i distinctly remember
it's one time of you there was a
basketball involved
and
i'd
whenever you would get upset
that you would get this look on your
face that would be like
like your eyes would get big and your
your lips would start moving
like but you're not saying anything
and then we'd be like greg you're uh
you're you're mad it's like uh
to tell us what what's going on and then
uh
i'd i'm sorry i don't remember anything
you were mad at apparently lindsay i
mean i never moved in on any girl that
you were clearly talking to because i do
remember that you were talking to
lindsay yes i remember that too yeah but
i do remember at another time you got
mad with a basketball and you threw the
basketball and
hit
was it through it tim
okay hit tim in the chest with it from
what i remember he was making fun of my
the skinniness of
of greg oh uh
speaking of third person here a very a
very sensitive subject for for myself
okay for greg
okay i didn't mean to bring up instead
of basketball another traumatic
experience on top of it but i think you
also got mad when we we we hugged it out
i think
we're hey that's one thing i mean this
is why i'm surprised that we never
talked about the the lindsay thing
because we were actually
yeah so junior year we lived together
and then of course tim joined
senior year but we were really good at
working i i think there was an emotional
uh
maturity there
that
i definitely think it came through these
for two of us yeah our involvement in
crew and just sort of like
you know this is these things are
important and like being real and being
vulnerable
is is important and so there was
like we would work through our issues
which is why i'm surprised that we
haven't we never talked about lindsay
until now
but
i do remember the time that we took your
uh
speaking of your label maker you had
slightly different tastes
yet you had like wilmington taste which
was elevated above the taste that you
know the buoys creek taste
so you would get like edie's ice cream
and we would get like the plastic
you know
bucket of ice cream from food lion
and you had this eating friend yeah
and
we were just sitting there one night you
weren't there and we were like man
greg's got that edie's ice cream
we needed and the color of the edie's
ice cream was very white very nice
vanilla you you had you had a taste for
the good the better oh yeah yeah yeah we
just didn't have those they're fine to
buy it
because because we we had communal
groceries
but then on top of communal groceries
there was something
you would have special stuff that you
just buy and label for yourself you had
labeled the 80s for yourself and because
everything else was communal with the
three and then the four of us
it was never enough because we weren't
willing to allocate enough money
we would we would split one hamburger
helper meal four ways four ways we did
it three ways and then when tim came
along we just went four ways if we
didn't get more hamburger helper we just
got less each but you had
so yeah the 80s ice cream so we ate
probably a third to a half of your
edie's pint
and then we took our cheap yellow
vanilla ice cream and filled it back up
and smoothed it out on top
and then your lips started to move
i do but did i get mad about that oh
yeah oh yeah i know i think you probably
thought it was hilarious that we tried
to no he tried to do it no i think he
got mad no way no way i got mad about
that
those are the days though man i've taken
all of our oldest videos
and
we're getting them digitized
so and because
on a you were an editor back then i once
once we really started moving into
uh
video editing later definitely when we
got into youtube i i like really wanted
to be the editor and took over for that
but like yeah it was interesting because
your dad had the two vcrs
that you became the default editor and
you would always throw
led zeppelin on it
so like that i mean you just kept going
back to led zeppelin we weren't even
huge led zeppelin fans but it was always
a great soundtrack it's like great for
it's very subversive music for a
christian christian organization okay we
kind of liked that aspect and barry
white as well yes it was like we were
like we're gonna play love making and
devil music in all of our videos that
we're making for crew yeah and again we
weren't like
we were super
zealous about our faith
but we did not like christian music
because we had taste
but for that reason
we can't put these videos out there like
the first videos that we made for our
first audience which featured
the two of you prominently and me
just in like feature roles or just
behind the camera like have never been
seen
except for
in front of those live audiences
but now
i'm going to put them on the mythical
society because of the led zeppelin of
it all that's the only place where we
can safely put it out there so yeah it's
gonna be behind a paywall but hey you
get what you pay for baby so uh
uh we're gonna do like a director's
commentary of this thing we could just
get rid of the soundtrack and voice over
all the parts again we could do that
yeah yeah so you guys have i'm sure
you've talked about the the calc have
you talked about the calculus uh jackass
story has has that been has that been
talked about before yeah oh my god yeah
yes but it's been said we've got to tell
that story again yeah rhett
i was right in the calculus class yeah
right and tim were in the calculus class
and um
and you know we go through the semester
i'm a back row seater all the way back
all the way back back quarter at closed
door and how many students
kind of had a sense of available but he
was
he he was a very like in control
professor right like he had control of
his classroom
and so at some point i just remember
thinking guys like how what would this
guy do i was like greg
if you'll stand up you know raise your
hand and when he calls on you stand up
and say i'm a jackass
at any point in the semester
i will buy you
a foot long
yeah
which is a big sandwich that's a big
sandwich so this is like halfway through
the semester this idea hatched
yeah it must have been but yeah through
the semester
rhett's like always kind of like
you know prodding me when are you gonna
do it
[Laughter]
they're doing the
they're you know we're doing the in the
semester uh
um exam it was yeah last day exam prep
last day of class
yeah this like uh the professor had just
gone over number nine i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure it was number nine
and he's asking is there any more
questions on number nine
and you know i raised my hand and he's
like yes
yes you in the back and i i stand up
and you know there's there's a pause
everyone turns around the scene because
you stood up like that wasn't it wasn't
a protocol to stand up
yeah and i and i say
i'm a jackass
and uh well the ta was sitting
nearby and he started laughing he was he
understood what was going on i think we
we had kind of run up by him to see what
what he would think we didn't want f's
in the class right yeah we i didn't want
to compromise you're great we meaning
you we me me i didn't want to test the
class do you remember what the professor
said because he was very quick what does
that make me yeah yeah
i mean i was like yeah pretty great i
mean it's just like he was so quick and
then what did everybody laugh then
sat back down and then we went to blimpy
and got a sub
[Laughter]
he got that sub baby there was another
incident similar rhett and i were at
carmichael and we were we were just i
were you playing you must be playing
basketball or something but there's
there's a group of guys
they're playing
21. uh isn't that isn't 21 where you're
just shooting the you know you're
playing one-on-one against everybody
against everybody yeah and red says hey
greg
i want you to get in there
and get that ball
and go in for a layup and and either
it's like i don't care if you make it i
just want you to like fall hard
[Music]
i do not play basketball
but i i i get in there in the mix i'm in
the mix i get the ball and i go for a
way up and i throw it as hard as i can
up into the rim
and it hits the rim and it hits me in
the face
and it and i
and i'm laid out and i you know
stop on the ground and um
those guys they i'm sure they've never
had a better website
yeah wherever you go greg you enrich
people's lives
i love that jackass like
you know i'm a jackass i look like i
love jackass humor to this day like one
of my favorite movies of the year is
jackass forever like i i just i love it
and again i love watching other people
do it i didn't take you i didn't go i
didn't i took shepherd of that movie
because you don't care about it right
and so it's like and greg was just like
the perfect up for anything yeah he was
like i'm totally going to do this and it
will
it'll get this reaction now so i mean
yeah we did
you were kind of
i mean you were the object of a lot of
humor
you were the subject of a lot of like
ideas that we would hatch it's like
because
i don't know it was kind of like we we
produced you
we were like comedy producers
so we just weren't filming it we should
have been filming it it wasn't like we
were puppeting you it was just like we
saw
like
yeah yeah i think as producers we saw
how funny you were and we wanted to
offer that up to the classroom or to the
pickup basketball court or whatever the
case may be it just seemed like we were
just packaging you as a gift to the
world and
uh you were always game for it and it
wasn't we weren't pulling one over on
you no no if if it was in that scenario
i would be the johnny knoxville and you
would be the stevo you know it's it was
a beautiful arrangement
and
the you you get the reaction that you're
looking for it's just we weren't
shooting any of it we were just but when
we did film stuff remembering it great i
mean it was like you'd have an idea and
then it would be like okay
this is gonna be funny but i don't
like i don't know how greg's what greg's
gonna do but i know it will be even
funnier than i thought like it's one
thing to do
if i did it right it wouldn't be funny
right right you know but it's not okay
it'll be funny if he does a layup but
what you don't know is that
he's gonna hit himself in the face by
accident i remember we were shooting
this video and i was setting up this
shot and i was like hey greg you've got
to run
around the corner and then into the
entrance to our dorm
and i'm filming it
i hope i can find this footage i'll show
it on the mythical society if i find it
you're running and you had these big ass
baggy jeans but you didn't have an ass
but and we always saw your crack man
your crack was always showing and you're
like running around the corner and then
as you i remember seeing this through
the camera clear as day you're running
you turn the corner and then as you're
running your pants start slowly falling
slowly falling down
uh to the thigh to the knee
to the ankle you didn't stop running
because you knew exactly what you were
doing you knew where you needed to go
and it's like okay he's going to make it
to his mark he's just not going to have
pants on when he gets there
and like i don't know you either fell or
didn't fall he got
he got steps from the door and fell down
you remember that
yeah yeah i remember i was i was still
running and the pants were all the way
down
but it wasn't we couldn't show that one
in the crusade cut but there was a video
where you were two completely naked
completely naked and you were playing uh
you were playing video games twisted
metal twisted metal and oh it's like oh
we for we didn't say oh [ __ ] but he's
like oh no we forgot that it's time to
be at the primetime meeting
that was one of the semesters opening
meetings was me and greg playing video
games naked
and i i framed it i don't know why they
let us get away with any of that where
you couldn't see your junk and then it's
like oh no they're naked they're playing
and then it's like oh no we gotta go and
then you both start to stand up but you
grab your book bags in such a way in the
perfect placement so that but like i
gotta give it listen you were probably
naked yeah you we were you know
naked i gotta give it to mark valentine
and mike mahaffey and todd smith for
letting that go through being cool with
that
you know
how they don't have any regrets about
how we ended up
but
it wasn't because of that
like they they you know they knew what
was important and they were willing to
have fun and it was like there you know
it's just a couple of dudes naked
playing video games as a joke it'll be
funny
so
first of all greg do you have any other
memories that you've jotted down i love
the fact that you actually made notes
like we've never seen you actually make
notes you've actually done homework this
is important this this conversation was
important anything else before no i i
just wanted to bring up one other thing
it was rhett's wedding uh rehearsal
dinner barbecue um pig picking yeah yeah
we had a pig picking yes uh yeah i was i
was at
i was at that function
and uh
you know everyone we're sitting in a big
circle right we sit in a big circle and
everyone's going around they're saying
you know
you know how wonderful rhett and jesse
are and um
like i i felt
the need to to say something
important
but i
big mistake big mistake
you should never sit me down and
give me the opportunity to say something
important but
so my observation has always been well
you know what happens the red will
happen the link or what happens a link
will like eventually like it's it's
going to happen
like if rhett does it like links link is
not far behind but uh
my my example was the snowboarding
incident ah we got snowboard for link
and a couple
weeks later go with rhett same same
thing we both got concussions
they've got concussions i didn't get a
broken pelvis though so were you
insinuating that i was gonna have sex
with rhett's wife yep that was the that
was the subtext that that
no
[Laughter]
after i got done like i sat down and
like after everyone else's you know nice
nice little
speech like everyone you know gave a
clap like clap or you know laugh but i
got nothing
you guys well the funny thing is like it
was you know that's a wonderful thing
about you know rehearsal and receptions
and stuff like that or that was like the
night before engagement thing is that
it's the whole mixed company thing so
you've got like family yeah and we were
bringing this
you were bringing that dynamic of i'm
gonna do something
uh i'm gonna be stressed that we would
have done just amongst us and but like
my grandparents were there
and so they're like who is that boy
i think i think that's you know i mean
we got a lot of love for you man this is
uh i mean this has been so fun like
catching up but i i think we've alluded
this in previous podcasts just to kind
of talk about like
where our friendship is now
and over the years i think you know
there was
um you know when we graduated and then
you went to you and jim went to
argentina for
on staff of campus crusade right first
tent yes for over a year like a year and
a half and then you came back and
did you you went somewhere else on staff
no no i i came back and um
we lived in raleigh for
three years we reconnected then right
yeah went back to school and um
yeah then we we did a lot of stuff with
you and christy right then we moved to
florida and uh then we moved to south
africa and here we are now in washington
right so and then florida south africa
and washington that was all uh
engineering
your engineering jobs yes but yeah i
mean i think that you know with with
distance and with us trying to get our
careers off the ground it was kind of
like
there was a drifting apart where like we
really didn't keep in touch that often
um
at least that was my recollection of it
well you know yeah i mean things get so
busy but you know when i was when i was
in south africa
we started talking again
we we made a way we made a way
thanks to the
the internet to talk that's right
because you and i had gotten yeah we had
that like second win when we were going
to church together and like what i said
about being adults and then so like i
think we carried on some of that and
then
um
and but even that started to kind of
uh dissolve over time of like being able
to keep in touch
and it was for a number of years it was
the pandemic that
um
you know i don't i don't remember like
it may have been harm's idea initially
for us to start talking on a regular
basis you know
um
so like that group of guys
from from state
and you know it's been we were better
about it earlier in the pandemic and
then as life has slowly sort of gotten
back to normal and people's schedules
have gotten back to normal it's been
more difficult but
one of the things that we have pulled
off is we've actually planned a get
together
i'm excited about that like the it's
it's like the tropish
middle-aged men
i still relive their college years by
going white water rafting in colorado
that's what i said on the group thread i
was like this is like the beginning of
either a horror movie no i said this is
like the beginning of like a thriller
where something goes wrong and then i
think tim said or a comedy like hot tub
time machine yeah this is very much like
middle-aged dudes who haven't hung out
in a while all getting together in one
house so when they're like
white water rafting we we've hung out a
few times you know over the years uh
seeing you guys and it's always like you
know
conversation picks up where it left
though but i am excited to do a to go on
a retreat together that's another level
yeah that is another level it would be
great it'll be good yeah i mean it's
just crazy um you know just to see
like i mean
you
you got all these children running
around you got three kids yeah i got
three kids yep i got three kids
you still got two kids i'm not gonna
catch up with you guys on that
but i mean what is it
i i'm just grateful that you know it's
like now we're i'm
we're reconnected we're like getting
together
of course that's assuming nothing bad
goes happen when we're on that raft i
might regret the whole thing but even if
it does i mean if it doesn't go too bad
it'll just be a good story and videoed
and we'll do that we're all gonna have
gopros on our heads but i think that um
you know i'm grateful for our friendship
and like
rhett and i talk so much about our
college years not only on this podcast
but just in normal life it's like like
you said earlier it was just such a
sweet spot of a time for us it was such
a dynamic experience
and
you know it would not have been the same
if you hadn't come into our lives and i
mean we became a trio and it was
something that
i mean rhett and i we talk so much about
how our friendship is one of a kind
and i mean definitely for those college
years
those three years saw sophomore junior
senior
especially sophomore junior year with
the where it was the three of us so much
i mean it was just such a special time
that few people have that
you know so
we just kind of fit together like a
glove and you know i wouldn't trade it
for the world it was just
super
super sweet
you know now that you reminded me of
those stories which i had
the jackass one of course i remember and
i've told i forgot about the basketball
one
so now we just got you know just prepare
yourself greg because we got to come up
with something for you to do and we all
get together
so
you're gonna have to say something to
the raft guide or something put your
hand on his knee or something i don't
know
well but we'll write it but we're yeah
and we will egg you on today and then
we're going to film it and then you will
make it better than we ever thought
you could this time there will be video
evidence it needs to be
well i know you got to go back to work
gotta you got to supervise the digging
of that hole so don't let us keep you
all right we'll be in touch
all right
this is the end this is the end this is
it greg
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]